hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to one finger death
punch I couldn't get enough of the
action and apparently you guys couldn't
either
so I'm eagerly back to play more of this
amazing amazing game but this episode's
gonna be a little bit different because
I want to actually progress a bit in
terms of a story here and show off my
skill of incredible measure I'm gonna
just play through a whole bunch of
levels that I'm going to show you like
the best most epic combos that I was
able to do and when I was losing my mind
the most it how good I actually am not
what theme to be good so here we go
speed round baby oh god damn it I wasn't
ready for it I didn't think they were
gonna be coming in fast and furious hey
got a broom I love a broom broom bring
it on everybody come shutting us kill if
they cook investment right
he'll tie my tralala
you cut my ding ding dong on the
defender I'll I know I'm a defender come
on huh
I ain't gonna kill anybody I'm just
gonna be very upset if I get hit by one
these goddamn knives oh oh so good oh so
good
I did it I got a platinum meadow root
yeah I need it perfect arou huh
bonk this isn't faster give me faster
faster come on come on a bra bank
turn Punk editing
I hit him so hard the dubstep started
pounding in my ears yes yes no no yes no
get it
yeah yes yes yes no no hello goodbye how
are you good how's neighbor house a
family on the home BAM job yeah it's
good
I didn't have fun with it
bang
blablablabla
lambda okay getting a bit more
complicated because it's go introducing
all these different enemies that I need
to remember the combos up so I can kill
them David's is so fun every part of it
is fun except I just missed it
I can barely even detect what's actually
going on as far as the animations go
like it could just be a [ __ ] of
nothing that makes any sense I wouldn't
even care because it was awesome hell
yeah I was gonna get you haha that was
tricky I had to pay attention to the
colors underneath the Mirza was gonna be
totally flubber next yeah all I got to
do smash stuff I love that that's my
favorite thing to do bomb
when the crash Bam Bam Bam Bam
I gotta arm up because I'm like ready to
punch things if they come at me my way
if anyone comes in rum ball recording
they're gonna get punched
probably not as elegantly is this I
probably just turn out to be one of the
great dudes I seen that they've been in
weather grip I turned out to be like a
prey in the background that's gonna
smash over and over again I'm trying to
understand the story behind this am I
just a mass murderer that's going
through the countryside just trying to
kill everybody that goes in my way
because it seems wait wait wait what do
you say cuz I wasn't paying attention I
was in my own little world talking about
the game and the story which I prize
didn't even care about it all but I did
power I'll just kill all it up Paula -
Paula - Paula - Paula - Paula - Paula -
Paula de oh [ __ ] now
make buck bang bang bang
ah yes now you were gonna give me with
that [ __ ] are getting a lot more
interesting and either I'm getting
better the gamer is getting just a
little too easy for me
oh thank you thank you for your
patronage to the death Society is one
one more delicious delicious round one
more please just one more delicious
round I can't stop it's a disease BAM
bum haha we think you could take me
playing baby Bing Bing Bing Bing would
you deserve Oh Philip I like everyone's
backs out of the way while I'm trying to
find one of the brawler dudes oh no your
head has floated whatever you're gonna
oh your head really didn't explode
didn't need to do that pink Bank remake
baby honk big what you
play to bed oh it's so deadly for you Oh
bonk hey how's it going hey family
what sambong
ha ha ha ha it's so good I'm so good I
didn't miss it all that time oh I think
it's a perfect way to end this game on
ok so I played through a lot of the game
there
I cut out a bit but not much you guys
saw pretty much all of it anyway cuz all
that was Rogers going oh be the way that
is more one finger death punch okay I'm
gonna put a longer break between this
one in the next episode unless you guys
just absolutely demand it but I want to
paste this out it's like this is one of
my favorite games of recent times
because it's so unrelentingly physically
fun for me it's so fun it's so fun
uh either way this has been one figure
death let's check out the other parts
I've done in the description below or in
the annotation up there thank you again
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed all the fun and as always I will
see you oh I'm not even good at this
game
and it feels like ever made
Oh
I don't know because I'm gonna edit this
and it's gonna be an amalgamation of
core that people are gonna see me oh my
gosh oh my gosh come on